the numbers are looking pretty good that
I'm going to be officially win as a
libertarian this time hi Matt Wells for
recent TV I'm here in Las Vegas at
Freedom Fest and i'm joined by the
highest-ranking elected libertarian
party official in the united states of
america at coleman from Indianapolis
City Council welcome and thanks for
joining us how did you win I used to
think i was a republican at one point in
time and i was very active in the
Republican Party and one day I said you
know I've been doing this for a long
time you know I've been in the military
for years and I was on my way out
because I was injured and I said you
know what I want to keep serving my
community because I think it's right to
serve the people and that was what I
felt my goal was in life and then I get
elected and I find out that politics
isn't very nice on the inside I was told
what to do I was told how to vote and
when I didn't do it I was treated like I
was some kind of a leper and nobody
wanted to be with me and they wanted to
bad-mouth me and I finally said wait a
minute this isn't the way things are
supposed to work so i started doing a
little bit of looking and i did a little
looking and a little more looking and
come to find out I'm not a Republican
after all I took the world's political
quiz I ended up in the very top corner
and I was like wow so I started
researching libertarian party I was like
I've been in the wrong place all these
years I need to do something that's
right and I need to leave my party and
go and do the right thing and start
helping build this party so did you win
first as a Republican and then switch
your party and when then as a
libertarian or how that worked I know
it's unheard of but I actually left in
the middle of my term in office i became
a libertarian and i am currently running
for reelection this year and as of right
now the numbers are looking pretty good
that i'm going to be officially win as a
libertarian this time what does an LP
guy do for Public Policy in a city
context what have you done I'll City
context is all about money mostly do
people feel safe do they feel like their
money's safe things like that when i
became a libertarian party member the
very first thing i did was put a
proposal into the city that passed i
think almost unanimously i had one to
center that requires the city to put all
of our contracts online so they can be
viewed by anybody you don't have to do
Freedom of Information requests anymore
I've become very vocal about stimulus
money grant money things like that I
feel like this is our dollars to begin
with
is the government giving it back to us
with strings why do they need need to
take it in the first place so I've
become a regular voter against any kind
of grant money every single time
something comes across that you know do
we want to give money to a big
billionaire like Jim Irsay out of the
Indianapolis Colts I'm like no we don't
he's already a billionaire you know he's
already getting enough from us why do we
need to keep giving it more just to keep
him here I fight against all the little
things that are ridiculous I'm fighting
against tax increases I fight against
when the government tries to come in and
do something to these small business
owners or property owners we have a
group that comes in and sites you
whenever you have high grass or you have
a fence out of place and I go down and I
fight on their behalf because it's their
property why is the government telling
them what they can do on their own
property so these are the kind of things
I focus on I try to keep it to what the
people need and not what some big law
firm or lobbyists or even with the guy
in the mayor's office once how come
there aren't more LP City Councilman
women in this country and how cannot
change well it's the same thing I tell
everybody somebody shakes my hand it
says I vote for you if you could win
well if I counted every single person
that says that guess what LP members
would probably start winning and then I
get guys who tell me you know you know
elected officials who are Republicans or
Democrats even sometimes you know I'd
become a libertarian party member if I
thought I could win but I think I could
do better being in office rather than
being a member of the Libertarian Party
out of principle my attitude toward that
is you're wrong you know if enough
people would do it and if people would
switch then we would have more of us so
my goal this year is to basically prove
everybody wrong and say look it can be
done best of luck with that and that's
all the time we have for for reason TV
I'm Matt well